[Applause]
Bravo white liberals you've entered the
conversation you've entered the chat
you've officially done it you have found
out how to do the least amount possible
to fake like you give a [ __ ] about
what's going on I am scrolling Instagram
as I'm sure you guys are all scrolling
Instagram today we see a lot of black
boxes you know and for the last week
some might say for the last 400 years
but for the last week there's been a lot
of talk about what we can all do how we
can all help right and I'm sure a bunch
of white people in you know executive
offices got together and they're like
what can we do to help how can we assist
the black plight in America how can we
be most effective you know should we
should we start a campaign we're all
donating money to various charities no
let's not do that that'd be too much
work and I would require too much money
should we start a campaign where we
raise awareness for like the local
district attorneys because those are the
people who end up deciding if people end
up getting tried or not especially cops
they're out there potentially killing
black people so we do that so we raise
win because you vote for those positions
who actually vote them in office so we
do that I know but it's just like you
gotta go out and like you know I mean
this covert outside you might have to
Google you have to research who those
local district attorneys are and then
that would take too much time you know
what I mean and so we can't do that um
you can hire black people and
administrative or executive positions
within the music industry you absolutely
could hire the black view of the
ministry executive positions wait I
don't have any black friends and I like
to hire my friends yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then they might get
economically empowered and then that
would be a whole [ __ ] rigmarole you
know a racial word it sounds it is that
what they call the aliens back in the
day
and rigmarole anyway I'm sure should we
do that are there any other ways where
we could we could help out in this
situation I mean like just a man police
reform a lot of different things all
these other things but you know what all
these probably came to the table during
the discussion and they're like listen
that's all sounds cute that's adorable
and will probably help I got a way
better idea how we could look as if
we're assisting but to absolutely
[ __ ] nothing yeah okay let's just
post a black square on our Instagram
feed which was a black square and answer
grant feeding because I know black
people and asking us for action right so
what do we do
Tuesday we're gonna do nothing literally
that's the campaign right hey why don't
we on Tuesday do nothing the exact
opposite of what black people have been
asking all week hey black well how can
we help you do anything please show that
you're with us support March say
something how about we just do nothing
is that good if we just post the color
black on our Instagram is there anything
less helpful than posting the color
black then screenshotting nothing on
your story and then taking that and
cropping it into your feet I just don't
know what the endgame is here I know the
endgame when you come back to work and
everybody's back in the office and they
go well what did you do oh you must not
see my black hey hey bro do you see my
black feet my [ __ ] was extra black bra
my [ __ ] was country black [ __ ] in the
background you know I mean like did you
put like a fist treat yeah little a
message
you saw that says black lives matter and
then it disappears hey bro that's that's
how unique you are yeah and your ability
to do the bare minimum bro
you bare minimums the maximum yeah I'm a
bare minimum Maximus hey dawg did you
send like a donation that was like faded
from the beginning and then came real
clear at then I I think you
misunderstood Oh
what I posted yeah on social media yeah
an Instagram the most political of all
apps oh that's where change happens
right bro that's what overthrew
governments right yeah I think it was
Instagram that overthrew brand that
overthrew the government yeah you're
right you're right solutions of started
Ram is the new revolution and I post
schindler's factory was just Instagram
right like this that's what it was
that's what he was just learning how to
create filters in that case it's not
owned by Facebook or anything absolutely
yes yes you post a black square and
what's more powerful throw me in a black
square a black rectangle a little bit
learned how to use all the space
possible finally you know you really
don't care about black people well you
don't even crop out the little rectangle
[Music]
you didn't even give them the bottom you
went landscape bra only Mexican is
allowed to Alaska
[Applause]